alors vous l'attendez on était obligé
bien sûr de vous en parler vous le savez
nabila a rejoint l'équipe 1 de touche
pas à mon poste depuis le début de
l'année elle est chroniqueuse avec toute
l'équipe a bien sûr et on va passer à ce
que la presse appelle déjà la sphère
nabila moi je vous le dit vendredi matin
à mon réveil j'ai reçu je sais pas
combien de textos j'avais 100 textos sur
la sphère un habile en a beaucoup hésité
avant de parler bien sûr de cette
histoire dans touche pas à mon poste
mais on se doit de le faire parce que
c'est une bien sûr elle fait partie des
missions et 2 c'est un fait médias dont
tout le monde parle donc on va le
traiter en quatre questions que ce soir
et il ya une question qui revient c'est
nabila va-t-elle revenir dans touche pas
à mon poste est d'ailleurs la question
qui revient sur twitter et sur boubou qu
on y répondra dans un instant pour le
moment j'aimerais savoir bien sûr ce que
vous en avez pensé vous et qu'est ce que
vous vous êtes dit vendredi matin quand
vous avez appris la nouvelle je vais
démarrer pape apparemment juju courbit
comme tout le monde je suis je vous ai
envoyé un texto d'ailleurs vendredi
matin parce que voilà je suis tombé des
nues ce qu'il faut bien préciser à tous
ceux qui nous regardent pas ce que c'est
très important c'est qu'on ne peut pas
dire n'importe quoi maintenant
voyez une une information d'une
sélection et ce pourrait se retourner
contre nous et ça pourrait même se
retourner contre nabil a donc moi je ne
sais absolument pas ce qui s'est passé
ça c'est le rôle de la jolie de la
justice de le savoir
tout ce que je peux dire j'étais pas là
je dis moi mais j'étais là mercredi ce
que je peux dire moi c'est le gvuc
ouacifs wannabe l'âge des vues 6 x 5 x
chroniqueuse et une fois en tant
qu'invité quand c'est moi quelques animé
le vendredi
voilà c'est une une fille franchement
simple elle arrive s p dans son coin au
maquillage elle très tatillonne sur sa
coiffure
voilà le prépare ses fiches et les
choque personne
voilà je vais vous dire nous on a été on
a été je sais pas le sentiment de chacun
et surtout le cas projet était très très
tristes de nouvelles quand je la prise
heureusement je vous le dit thomas est
sortie d'hôpital et ça c'était vraiment
le plus important donc apparemment il
rappelé donc le compagnon de nabila
qu'on connaissait donc nous très peu
puisqu'on l'a vu de trois fois ici aussi
avec elle et c'est vrai que la première
chose moi c'était un sentiment de
tristesse que j'ai eu concernant cette
affaire vous gilles verdez questions
quels sentiments vous avez eue vendredi
matin bon qu'on réponde aux différentes
questions à une immense tristesse pour 1
immense gâchis moi j'aime nabila je
parle pas de la sphère sais pas ce qui
s'est passé ça on sait rabastens et
d'ailleurs personne ne le sait pour
vraiment chaque fois par exemple vous
savez le matin vers 9 heures on allait
les audiences quand je lui ai envoyé un
message quand elle avait participé à une
émission je suis l émission où tu étais
hier ça a bien marché elle me répondait
elle était super heureuse donc c'est que
c'est quelqu'un qui s'implique
énormément dans l'émission qui bossent
et qui adore participer à cette émission
c'est son bonheur cette émission voilà
mais alors là on connaît pas bien sur la
nature des faits c'est sûr mais si les
faits sont avérés c'est vrai que ce sont
des classes est grave donc c'est
difficile d'en parler ce soir donc on ne
sait pas du tout c'est pas si on n'était
pas avec eux c'est vrai comment je
connaissais pas trop les relations entre
elle et thomas avoue isabelle morini
bosc
ah mais moi j'étais à main évidemment
abasourdi comme tout le monde et moi
j'ai effectivement été très triste et je
le suis toujours assez avec nabila on
avait commencé à discuter son plein de
trucs de l avait elle commencé ça vous
semblez tout con elle avait commencé à
avoir envie d'apprendre
l'émission de mac lesggy sur l'histoire
je pense que c'est la presse qu'elle
entendait parler d'histoire et qu'elle
regardait elle a adoré les chansons
quand un jour aurait dit ouais c'est des
vieilles chansons ses visées mission ça
m'intéresse pas après elle me dit
j'adore colchiques dans les prés dans
les prés est ce que tu peux me faire des
textes deviennent jamais rien apporté
non mais ça veut dire que avec nous
c'est vrai que sincèrement j'ai le
sentiment qu'elle s'épanouisse est non
sincèrement et laura oui oui non mais
c'était on était tellement tous sous le
choc après malheureusement qu'on n'est
pas les gens donc on aime on connaît pas
les gens c'est pas comment ils sont dans
la vie on sait pas comment ils sont dans
leur couple moi ça m'attriste surtout de
constater que voilà encore une fois moi
ça m'aide malheureusement de l'eau à mon
moulin c'est tous ces jeunes de télé
réalité sont des gens fragiles qui n'ont
pas eu forcément des vie facile et qui
malheureusement pour certains d'entre
eux ont maintenant des caraman des
destins tragiques alors à la collégienne
petit ami thomas aussi dans une télé à
vannes
absolument et les deux ce sont des gens
vraiment pourrait avoir autant envie
d'être dans la lumière comme ça pour
sait qui c'est qu'à la base il ya
quelque chose qui va pas et sa matrice
pour eux pour ce couple pour cette jeune
fille que nous découvrions en coulisses
et qui était évidemment charmante qu'on
apprenait vraiment tous les jours à
découvrir un peu plus c'est un drame
c'est un drame pour eux pour leurs
familles l'essentiel vous l'avez eue
avec thomas et bien ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle d'un bien rejouer ce que
enora sais que tu sais malheureusement
des drames comme ça de gens qui font
safari et lrm chaque année par jour
je sais pas si on peut vraiment pas
pressé que mon avis je reste toujours
malheureusement que tout ce qu'elle
subissait comme pression alors ça ça n'a
rien à voir avec la faire mais c'est pas
facile juste voilà de vivre ce qu'elle
vit en ce moment en étant en plus sous
les feux des projecteurs à ce point je
veux dire c'est ça et pour thomas pour
les deux jeunes vers des vins bilal
était à mon avis dépassé par sa propre
personne c'est pour ça que c'est
infernal à gérer parce que c'est un
phénomène c'est un phénomène médiatique
c'est un phénomène presque sociale et ça
c'est impossible à gérer pour un être
humain donc parfois on est totalement
débordés parce qu'il ya autour de soi on
ne s'appartient plus en quelque sorte
jean michel mr oui moi je n'en revenais
pas de message que comme j ai pas pris
son numéro un donc un vrai beau pas de
la grèce ouvrit à norbert alors oui et
voilà mais pour la voir évidemment
côtoyé comme tout le monde rigole
jacques peyrat j'ai le sentiment voilà
que comme tous les gens qui ont latérite
et ils ont des sentiments qui sont à
fleur de plo et que tout est un peu
exagéré donc les légeois sont exagérées
les peurs les angoisses les peines et c
est moi par exemple même si elle avait
cherché la notoriété est l'oeuvre
jouissez et voilà elle voulait le faire
mehdi mais à chaque fois ce que je sors
de tpm p il ya beaucoup de gens qui
aiment pour moi ça me fait autant peur
que plaisir parce que voilà je suis
obligé de les affronter
jean luc a évidemment moi j'étais
choquée j'ai entendu ça à la radio comme
tout le monde
en plus c'était le premier titre il ya
eu dix avaient d'autres trucs dans
l'actualité c'est prévoir par les
jusqu'après justement d'être assez
étonnant moi j'ai du mal à vous en
parler au passé d'entendre ça ou pas
c'est parce que bon on sait pas ce qui
s'est passé exactement
laissons faire la justice on verra bien
si oui non mais non mais c'est sur une
nouvelle fois là c'est pas forcément le
fait qu'elle soit connue et c'est ya des
gens en colère chéri des drames
familiaux etc
j'aime la télé n'a peut-être strictement
rien à voir avec ça on ne sait rien
c'est moi
je pense que ça existe en six reports
avoir été excusé moi sans prétention
celle qui lui parlait un peu le plus je
pense que c'est exacerbée vraiment sa
fragilité
je crois pas que c'était jury jean luc
jean luc je crois pas mais le moins en
tout cas dans la joie et vendredi je me
suis dit je me répète nabila pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai eu un drame quand même
on sait pas ce qui s'est passé personne
ne le sait bien mais quitte à l'hôpital
aussi et il ya eu toute la journée mais
tout le monde a fait partie de son
commentaire a fait des fois des blagues
honnêtement il ya des certaines qui me
faisait rire mais d'autres qui étaient
franchement limité certains qui
voulaient faire un bon mot juste pour se
faire mousser là dessus et qu'en
politique c'est quand même bizarre c'est
que il n'ya pas du tout de respect de la
personne
ça m'a choqué oublie on a oublié à ce
moment-là l'être humain parce que c'est
un phénomène express et nomen la ville
et on a oublié qu'il y avait des
familles qui avait deux familles la
famille de nabila la famille thomas et
que si l'hiver mais surtout autour de
nabila on sait pas ce qui s'est passé
bien il ya bien sûr la présomption
d'innocence donc c'est pas du tout c'est
passé moi le sentiment que j'ai
aujourd'hui
j'étais très très tristes vendredi je
vous lis parce qu'en plus j'avais parié
vraiment sûr nabila j'espère donc voilà
que l'on n'en sera vite qui s'est passé
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
j'avais on avait parié sur nabila ici
dans touche pas à mon poste et on était
assez content nous de son travail ici au
sein de l'émission dth et aux leaders de
la santé oms corps était aussi réalisé
les sorts ou nabila étaient des faux pas
n'a pas vraiment fait partie aussi de
d'une souris de tous mes vérités mission
voilà l'album archimaine nabila aussi
avait sa place dans dans dans l'émission
et c'est vrai qu'elle a apporté aussi à
l'émission on ne crache pas dans la
soupe et moi je vous le dis ici
si l'un d'entre vous alors là il ya
vraiment ya la présomption d'innocence
je sais pas du tout ce qu'elle a fait
mais n'importe lequel d'entre vous si
vous aviez un problème de tel ou tel de
n'importe quelle sorte c'est vrai que
d'abord ma place
le premier réflexe que j'aurai ce serait
de vous aider après voilà donc le même
réflexe pour nabila j'espère voilà pour
l'instant j'espère que les faits sont
pas aussi grave qu'on le dit mais je
savais revoilà qu'on va savoir c'est si
qu'on embrasse simplement sinon merci
mais moi et je vous dis je pense que
c'est vrai je suis juste heureux que
thomas soit sorti de l'hôpital et qu'il
aille mieux et que j'espère que cette
affaire va va vite de se régler mais
c'est vrai que c'est assez triste et moi
c'est vrai que vendredi
je vous le dis franchement on avait fait
un record d'audience jeudi le channel j
ai même pas pensé de voyager en fait
j'avais même pas vu j'avais tout était
un truand records d'audience et après
j'ai appris la faire daby là donc c'est
vrai que j'ai
j'étais vraiment très triste et ça fait
deux trois jours vraiment que j'ai pensé
que je pensais pas ce qu'elle faisait
partie mineure de la famille touche pas
à mon poste voilà et donc on espère
voilà que ça on va vite faire la lumière
voilà sur ce drame et l'important le
redis encore une fois c'est que thomas
aille mieux